good morning
i'd like to open the
uh april 25th session of the science
technology and energy commission
committee i'd like you all to rise and
join representative mcgee as she leads
us in the pledge of allegiance
okay thanks to you all for being here
today we have just one
major item on our agenda today and that
is to resume the executive session on
senate bill
but before we get to that we have a
couple of other issues to uh discuss
discuss briefly
first i'd like to welcome back to the
committee representatives kelly and the
flam who are substituting today
as they did
last week for representatives
vincent and
pimentel
so welcome gentlemen nice to have you
back
and
secondly i'd like to turn the microphone
over to representative thomas to discuss
activities in the month of may
yes good morning it apparently we have
a bunch of tuesdays that are available
in may where we don't have committee but
we have opportunities to do
field trips to various places so i would
like to get
uh maybe not the second but
i would like to get your opinion and um
uh uh
uh
suggestions on where we might go
uh if we want to do all four tuesdays or
if we can't do that maybe we can do two
of them
but
if we have any suggestions i'm willing
to take them and we can start planning
and see and just see which ones uh
the speaker will approve us to go
so that's that's one
one thing uh secondly um
we're coming out of a long drought
of uh
camaraderie here where we used to at the
end of the
term have a committee luncheon
uh taking our office assistant with us
and our our researchers
and so i'm open to suggestions on
whether you would like to take advantage
i know we don't have any
committee schedule where you're going to
be here anyway but for those that might
like to come back here to do a committee
luncheon um i would take that suggestion
i i think we should
uh i i you know i i don't think if
angelina's is still open we used to go
there it was it was a great place to eat
but is it open yeah they're real oh they
reopen great well perhaps we can do that
again or we can try to try some other
endeavor but uh i'm i'm welcome to uh
suggestions on whether you want to or
not and if so when last week in may
maybe or someplace just before session
i'm open
so we want to hear your thoughts about
a committee lunch
but
before we get to that
uh i'd point out that we
sent several bills this year to interim
study
and we could form some subcommittees and
begin work
on the interim study
activity
in the month of may and if we
did some of that work on the same day as
a luncheon was scheduled then that would
get every give everyone um just cause to
drive here to to participate so and get
paid
and get paid that's correct
so uh factor that into your discussions
about uh whether we should get together
for lunch or not so
let's hear your thoughts and your ideas
representative oxenoum
thank you mr chair uh is there any
further information on the block island
trip
sadly no um i
i had not i have been not being
contacted since uh i was about over a
month ago or actually probably going on
five weeks now
uh the tentative date was the i think
june
9th i think or what i
i think was
um i need to get back and find out uh if
there's still planning to to do it or
not so thanks for that reminder
further discussion representative santic
thank you mr chairman i had been talking
to some people from the new hampshire
electric co-op and as we probably all
know
they have a huge solar array up in
moultonborough
and if that was something we might be
interested in visiting
they're very open to that so
good suggestion thank you representative
partial
that's like sure another uh subject um i
think the idea of a lunch is absolutely
splendid i like the idea of a working
session
and i'd like to put a bug out there for
the idea of taking another look at the
5g bill that i think is was going to be
sent to interim session uh
study or to a work session oh absolutely
i i have plans um to start have at least
one
subcommittee meeting between now and
i thought maybe the first part of june
might have been good but we'll look at
as may but i i plan to have at least one
and maybe uh one or two in the in the
fall
absolutely so it's perfectly uh
acceptable for you to make suggestions
about interim study subcommittees at
this point in time representative
lewicki
thank you mr chairman um one that we
really were serious about was the one on
the uh cell phone radiation and i really
would like to be on that one
yes that's the 5g build that we just
discussed
thank you for reminding us about that
any other discussion
it would be nice to re
refrain from discussing it amongst
yourselves and just discuss it with
everybody here
okay all right
representative cambrils
okay
so we're signing up for things
all right
so i i don't have a strong sense here
yet whether we're gonna try to get
together for lunch so let's have a show
of hands
from existing committee members who
would like to get a get together for an
end of session lunch
all right that's great that looks pretty
uh like a pretty positive response
so if we could combine
a
end of session lunch with a stub
subcommittee work session on an interim
study bill
in the same day
that would be
the ideal situation
does any tuesday in may work
for
folks
there's may 3rd may 10th may 17th and
may 24th
does anyone have
a preference
about what day we might choose to engage
in some of this activity representative
oxenam
unfortunately i've got a series of
medical appointments on tuesdays because
i figured those were days that would be
available so i know nick the coming
tuesday is a bad one for me so if it
could not be that tuesday uh okay we can
rule out may 3rd so that leaves the 10th
the 17th and the 24th
anybody feel strongly one way or the
other about any of those dates 17th is
not good for myself
17th is bad
okay so now we're down to the 10th
the 10th is not good either
24th looks best
24th
could we all set aside
may 24th as as the
date of our end of session lunch
and hopefully we can put together a
subcommittee
to study
one of the interim study bills on that
day as well
so since we're on that subject
let's talk about interim study bills
representative cali pitts
yeah i can reach
if we're going to
uh
have a luncheon i i think one
i know the first time i ever went to a
committee lunch
i was surprised that it was on you so i
think that needs to be that
it's on us when we go to lunch
um
normally
we pay for it that's
the uh other one is that if you're going
to have work sessions
why not open it to the whole committee
if we're going to be doing it that day
so i would think that
there are a number of topics that were
of interest to most of the committee
and that anyone usually when you open a
work session you have anyone who wants
to come can come
and and
we should all be
i think invited and interested and on
the subcommittees i know 5g was very
interesting to me
um
and there are several others so i i
think that might be the wisest thing to
do
excellent points uh
so on your first point
any
committee lunch would be
a
dutch treat you pay for yourself
actually what we typically do is we
add up the bill and then split it
by the number of people who are there
yes yes we do pay for the committee
researcher and the committee uh
admin yes an important point you're
right
so that's a that's a good point thanks
for bringing that up representative
kelly pitts as to your other point
i think interim study studies need to be
done by the full committee not by a
subcommittee so i may have
misspoken earlier when i said
subcommittee i meant the full committee
would
undertake those interim studies
representative partial
yes thank you chair um again and i
believe that the 5g was not actually
meant to be an interim study
but i um work group
was that the intent of that well we we
voted to go to interim study oh it was
okay yeah thanks this one
expressed me the representative mcgee
three
bills on interim study that for our
consideration if we
uh
hb 1248
relative to replacement power for net
metering customer generators
and then uh 1635
relative to the purchase of output of
limited electric energy produces and
including qualifying storage
and the last one was the 5g bill
1644.
representative samsic thank you
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman um
i i wouldn't be able to attend on the
24th of may because i'm going to be in
germany at the time
so but that would not preclude if that's
the best day for everybody that's fine
with me
okay
thank you
as representative plett said
any further discussion i i do think that
we should interim study 1248 and 1635 as
well
um and the 5g bill is probably going to
take
a long time several hours if not
longer
so
is there any feeling amongst committee
members about which bill you would like
to do on the 24th the day we've picked
for
a session lunch
no strong feelings okay i'll talk to
representative thomas and we'll pick one
and we'll let you guys know
once we have a chance to do that
all right so is there any further dis
representative oxenum
please forgive me i i seem to have taken
next tuesday off the table very quickly
for my own personal preference i didn't
realize that our noble leader would not
be available on at the end of the month
i can possibly i think i can move my
appointment on that day so
is
is the coming tuesday available to
people so that we could include uh
representative samsic in our discussions
okay let's have a show of hands how many
people would be available next tuesday
which is may 3rd
if we're gonna do next tuesday the third
i have to post it
today or tomorrow probably so um
it does take us right into session with
the two following days i'm hearing
around the room yeah three days yeah we
do have a session that week on the fifth
that would be that would be three days
in a row forgive me for bringing it up
sorry
yeah
so
with apologies to
samsich uh who obviously made travel
plans some time ago
uh it looks like we may have to do the
24th instead
i can't feel sorry if he's in germany
though
but
we wish you safe travels to uh to
germany and
we'll look forward to
hearing about your trip when you get
back
all right i think that takes care of of
our discussion of where we're going
after this meeting is over today
and so i think we can move on to the
business of the day so i'd like to
resume the executive session on senate
bill 271
and i would like to
move the adoption
of amendment number 2022
h
to senate bill 271 and i recognize
representative thomas second
so it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt
amendment
h
and i'm sure there'll be lots of
discussion and i'm going to start the
discussion first by explaining what this
amendment does
this is a fairly simple amendment it's a
substantial change from the original
bill
as you will recall the original bill
proposed
for giving a 58 million dollar what will
be a 58 million dollar debt
incurred by
uh
burgess biopower
a ratepayer debt essentially
the original bill forgave that debt
and allowed the plant to continue
operation under its current model
what this amendment does
is instead it extends
the
cap that was
placed on over market payments
by the 2018 senate bill 577
for another year
it further requires burgess biopower to
open its books
to the department of energy for an
investigation into its
future financial operation
this
amendment does not solve the problem
that burgess bio power
faces
and i acknowledge that
but there did not seem to be on the
immediate horizon
a solid solution to that problem
therefore it seems prudent to me
to spend more time investigating
whether there can be
a satisfactory
solution
to this problem
this bill will give us that time
another year
and
i know there's a lot of discussion
that's been going on amongst various
stakeholder parties
about what a future permanent solution
may look like
i'm confident
that such a solution
will emerge
in the next year
therefore i think it's prudent
to pass this amendment
provide the additional time that's
needed to study this question
come up with a solution and then resolve
it
permanently to the
to the best ability
the to the
to the extent that we can
well the the solution we come up with be
perfect
probably not
will it be politically
uh
controversial
probably
but it's it's
just because something is hard to do
doesn't mean you should avoid trying to
do it
i fully expect
that a permanent solution to this
problem will be hard to do
but we have to try
and we have to stop
doing what this amendment does kicking
the can down the road but the reason
this amendment kicks the can down the
road is because we need the time
to come up with that permanent solution
so that's why i'm proposing this
amendment
and now i'm anxious to hear your
thoughts about it representative
harrington
thank you mr chairman
[Music]
i know we're talking about the amendment
but i just wanted to mention a couple of
things about the original bill because i
think we deserve to to bring that up i
don't think i've ever seen a bill that
was this open-ended where it turns
around and says the public utilities
commission shall amend any of its orders
as necessary to protect the continued
operation of the burgess bio plant i
don't think new hampshire's ever had a
bill like that we sold some private
company no matter what you do no matter
how badly managed you are no matter how
much you waste or don't waste money
we're going to keep feeding revenues to
you so you can't close that's an
open-ended never-ending promise of
unlimited funding when i asked the main
sponsor he said whatever whatever it
takes whatever it cost that's just bad
legislation
besides that fact i don't think the bill
is uh correct in that it tells the puc
what they have to do my understanding is
that a utility can bring a purchase
power agreement to the puc
and the puc can rev review that and they
can either approve it disapprove it or
say we'll only approve if you make the
following change but they don't have the
authority to make utilities sign a
purchase power agreement the puc can't
dictate in this case to ever source you
will supply unlimited amount of funds to
burgess biomass whatever they say they
need you'll give them so i don't think
that that's even legal
and the third thing i want to mention
here is if you look across the scope of
new england almost every power plant
over the last 20 or 25 years we've gone
from a regulated to a less regulated
market has been bought and sold most of
them many times up to and including the
biggest one in the state which is the
two nuclear in new england the nuclear
plant seabrook and also the nuclear
plant down in millstone i mentioned the
londonderry plant down in which was a
gas-fired plant which at one point i
think the original owners just walked
away and said
to the bank it's yours
and i think it's been sold a couple more
times since then but now it's operating
and it's running at a profit at least
it's not getting a subsidy from the rate
pay as i can tell you that
and that they continue to operate so the
point i'm trying to make here is just
because the present ownership of burgess
biomass goes away doesn't mean the plant
goes away they can go in this this is
one of the things that this year will
give them is a year to negotiate with
anybody out there and maybe they'll have
to sell it for quote pennies on the
dollar like was done in the londonderry
plant but just because this ownership
group leaves doesn't mean the plant's
going to be shut down and in fact
there's probably a price out there
somewhere if you drop it down enough
where the plant is viable i don't know
where that is i'm not an expert at how
much it costs to run a wood burning
plant but i know that we've also been
told by the some of the other wood
burning plants for the last i don't know
10 15 years that they're going to close
if they don't get additional subsidies
on top of the rps
and yet one plant is still open so there
must be a way to do it if you can work
your numbers right
so
i i just think that we we have to look
at some options as the chairman said
this gives a year but the big thing is
it opens up the books we don't know
exactly what it is the original bill
i i would assume uh
whatever is necessary to protect the
continued operation would burgess would
just send eversource a bill every month
and say here's how much extra money i
need to keep running this allows the
department of energy to go through the
books and see exactly what their costs
are the revenues and come up with an
honest assessment of what's going on at
that plant which we haven't been able to
do up until now does it kick the can
down the road a little bit yeah but in
the year we're going to pick up the can
and read what it says on the label
because we're going to know the finances
of the burgess biomass plan what it's
going to take to make that a viable
entity they'll stay going forward
without huge ratepayer subsidies and
just don't forget about one other thing
remember this plant because of the
contract with the ppa they got 27
million dollars in rps payments for rex
that's more than anybody else gets
that's 27 million dollar bonus for being
green and yet they say that's not good
enough even with 27 million dollar bonus
they still can't run so i think we
really need to look at the ownership
structure there and it's time to start
thinking about possibly selling the
plant because it just isn't going to
work under the way it is right now and i
strongly recommend we approve this
amendment
thank you representative callie pitts
let me preface my remarks by saying i i
want the plant to stay open but there
are two things
that i
i'm not sure about one i thought that
the
problem was the 58 million
that's already been collected
and that
that is see that was the wedge and
that's what we were looking to forgive
so this bill or that's what they were
looking to get forgiven this bill does
not do that as far as i can see and i'll
bring up the second problem or the
second
question i have
is that if the puc is
quasi judiciary
how can the legislature
dictate to them
what they shall do and i
i don't know if there's other wording or
other ways about it but i was not quite
in sync with that particular paragraph
so if those questions could be answered
i'd really be happy
thank you representative kelly pitts
to your first question you're right this
bill does not forgive the 58 million
dollars
as the original bill that came over from
the senate did
and
the reason it doesn't do that is because
those are
rate payer dollars
and
it doesn't seem prudent to just give
away 58 million of ratepayer dollars
to answer your second question
the poc is a regulatory
agency ultimately as is the department
of energy or many of the functions of
the department of energy and legislative
activity
is the guide they use
to make their regulatory decisions
so the legislature can tell
the poc and the doe
what to do in broad strokes
and
it's perfectly legitimate i think
for
this amendment
and this legislature to say we think
this is the best course of action going
forward
representative platt has a comment but
what
just uh clarification from
representatives i wanted to follow up my
my understanding from the hearings
that we had was that the 58 million that
we were talking about has already been
collected
so it would not be an additional
subsidy am i correct in that assumption
i believe that is correct yes
representative platt yes i endorse all
of the comments made by my colleague
representative harrington with one minor
exception when he said next year maybe
we can come out with
something that doesn't have huge
ratepayer subsidies i would amend that
to say without any ratepayer subsidies
okay thank you
further comment representative mann
you mr chairman um
it seems to me that the scope the proper
scope of this problem is much bigger
than the burgess
plant that it encompa it's really about
the economy
of that area up there and um
it's almost like um
uh we're being held hostage by the fact
that we can't just throw away all kinds
of jobs
so um
i think as a parallel effort it might be
useful to
set up a commission to study
that economy and not come up with
possible ideas either to just turn it
back into wilderness or
find another um
way for that part of the world to uh by
part of our state to
be economically viable there was a
plan once about
and i don't know much about it but i
know there was a talk about a plan
to have a large
greenhouse producing fresh vegetables
be around up there and it would be a
major um
economic uh support i would think
so i think um
a big in addition to what we're doing
here i think we should be recommending a
much larger scope
investigation thank you
i would agree with you that
a permanent solution is not just a
solution for this one particular bio
mass plant
but is actually a solution for the
forest products industry that's
the most important
and statewide
interest that we can serve here is to
take care of the forest products
industry
further comment representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
uh i just had a couple of comments on
comments that have already been said um
i noticed that we're discussing how the
department of energy is now
also a regulatory body in addition to
the public utilities commission and i
did think that in our discussion of hb2
and the um you know when the department
of energy came into being
we had several discussions about the
bright red line between regulatory and
executive or administrative functions of
that agency
and my concern was that the lines be
blurred and it seems that that's what's
happening now is that we're saying well
if we want some regulatory decisions we
can just put it
into this agency of the executive branch
so i have a concern about that but the
other thing i wanted to mention is that
it it discard it's discouraging to me
that when we talk about
these very you know sophisticated power
purchase agreements that were put
through
um an in-depth process where the
stakeholders had agreement that we as a
committee because we weren't personally
at the table or we don't understand the
details are saying we need to know more
i actually don't think
that the financials of the burgess
biomass plant
are
opaque
i think it's just that we personally
have not seen those
and so
my question would be
this bill is vague and what it does is
it it doesn't just kick the can down the
road it it continues the problem that
we've had already
um the reason eversource ratepayers are
are on the line for this money is
because of the power purchase agreement
the money was collected because
that was agreed what what we were being
asked to do with sb 271 i believe
is to say that the plant itself was not
on the line for coming up with all of
that money that it was going to be a
wash that we were going to allow in
order to let them go forward and they
offered
to put language in the bill that said
there would be no further subsidies from
the ratepayers so the thing that folks
on the panel are saying they desire was
offered by the plant we didn't take that
solution and now we're saying
without any details or directives about
what would be suitable in terms of what
we're going to find in the books
we don't have any
uh
we don't have any details about what
hurdle the plant is required to meet
in order to continue um so i have a lot
you know i i'm a co-sponsor on this
because i want to see us resolve it
but i also
have questions about what it is we're
actually trying to
achieve with this amendment because
we didn't
we didn't give the solution that that we
were asked uh to provide
and we also haven't given any definition
to which solution
would be acceptable
i guess that's where i would leave it
right we're saying
there's something out there we don't we
don't know and we are not giving any
direction on
and when you know we're leaving
everything up in the air which i think
is
is a weak position for us
and for the state
okay thank you i would respond to that
by pointing out
that the language offered by the
company
there was grave concern amongst several
parties who looked at that language
about whether it was achievable
and
one of the things that
this one year extension will do
is allow people time to determine
whether that in fact is achievable and
if it is then maybe it'll go forward
at a future date but not today
representative harrington
thank you mr chairman just in the way of
a little background as to some little
bit of history on this in the past we
had a thing called qfs which were
qualified facilities and this has come
out of the federal government some years
ago and basically
it was it was determined that renewable
generators like the small hydros and
small wood burning plants could be paid
what we expected the market rate to be
in the future
so while
prices for electricity were four and
five cents a kilowatt hour they were
getting paid 15 and 16 cents a kilowatt
hour that all added up to around 2
billion dollars in over market rates
that were paid to these qualifying
facilities so the whole reason for the
cap in this one was when it was
negotiated for the ppa it was decided
wait a minute everyone look into the
future it's going to be difficult to
determine no one knows what the energy
price is going to be
a year from now if you figure it out let
me know because then we can both be rich
but
so that was put in as a safety valve for
the rate payers so if if when things
went along and as it turned out after
this agreement was signed elect
wholesale energy prices actually went
down for a number of years now they're
trending back up but it was to maximize
the amount that the um that the
ratepayers would have to pay and once it
got to a certain amount that the biomass
plant was supposed to start paying them
back all terms of which they agreed with
and
now they want to change that now you
mentioned they sat here and said that
there's no additional cost but you know
what that's not in the bill anywhere
what is in the bill is the public
utility should amend its orders as
necessary to protect the continued
operation regardless if you heard
senator bradley regardless of what it
takes regardless of the cost so the fact
that they say we might not be asking
more money does not give me a warm
feeling this bill would allow them
unlimited
funding the way it was proposed and i
think what we have here is a compromise
that gives us a year to look at it we
open up their books we have a better
idea of what's going on with really what
their costs our expenses are and it also
gives them that time to look into the
possibility of selling the plant because
like i said i don't think there is a
maybe there's one or two out there but i
think the overwhelming majority of
plants uh generating plants in new
england have been sold at least once
since we started restructuring in the
late 1990s
representative sausage
thank you mr chairman
um
i want to say that i have a lot of
respect for senator bradley
and i think that as as office holders
elected office holders
i personally believe that one of the
my primary
obligation
is to ensure that i don't destroy
anybody's jobs in new hampshire that's
their livelihood
and therefore i'm going to do a lot of
things to make sure that that doesn't
happen
and yes
i agree with representative harrington
about a need for oversight that
this is not an open-ended checkbook that
they can charge whatever they want and
have all kinds we can we could do
something to restrict that and i also
agree with representative owes on the
idea that this is not a permanent
solution this is just gives us some
extra time
um however
when i look at the amendment to i i
noticed that the amendment clearly
undervalues the value of this facility
previously where the original wording
was something like essential
or invaluable now it's just valuable and
maybe needed and so forth and you know
the fact that this is a renewable energy
plant the only one of that kind of
magnitude in our state and that it
provides all kinds of ancillary benefits
to
health and welfare everybody including
the timber industry but also the rest of
the state
i think that's a reason in an election
year particularly not to do anything
destructive in this situation yes we
need a permanent solution and and we
should work on that and i agree also
that that
support or whatever we want to call it
should not be coming just from
ratepayers it could be coming from a
more broader base of new hampshire
residents that is a good idea we don't
have time now to resolve this today
so i am not going to be voting for this
amendment i i support the original bill
as is and i believe that we can do
things that we could make sure we can
put some kind of guard rails in place
for
next year to uh if we decide this goes
ahead for the time being as is then we
should
have the opportunity to modify if we
feel that there is a better solution
long-term to it
so
like i said i'm not going to vote for
this as is and
but i understand the hard work that was
put in and i understand the fact that
this one year extension is better than
nothing
uh now i'm a scientist but i have an mba
in business as well and i know that if a
one-year extension is not very valuable
for a business they can't plan for a
year they can't plan for the future what
they can plan for is how they're going
to sell it or get out of the business
and close shop within a year so i think
this is actually
a bill that really is sending a message
we don't support this plan
right now there's no guarantee we will
support it in the future obviously in a
net collection year we like to pretend
to support things but i have no
confidence that this is a good bill with
the amendment i would much sooner see
the original bill go through and maybe
we can modify those terms in the future
or we can put some kind of guard rails
in place so thank you mr chairman
representative merner
thank you mr chair
when we passed 577
three and a half years ago
the year after we passed this the
electric wholesale electric rates went
crashing i have small hydros up there
that
friends of mine and partners own i mean
two and a half cents on the open market
i know we went through a time
obviously that was uncertain so you know
this didn't play out the way we wanted
it to play out back when we passed the
bill which i endorsed back in
whatever year it was three and a half
years ago
2018.
thank you thank you mr chairman
so you know there's a lot of factors
that played into this so i think it's
really really important that we look at
this for the next year now that the
market has totally changed in the last
six months everything's totally changed
it's been turned on its head
i mean we had an average daily price of
a 135 dollars a megawatt in the month of
january when the year before it was 30
dollars so you know things have changed
and to the point on the low grade wood
thanks to uh
my uh vice chair
and myself and i think janine is on the
bill we have a low-grade wood commission
that has just passed it went through
reckon resources and it just passed the
senate so we're gonna have a low-grade
wood commission that we can look at
we're looking there's a big plant that
was proposed up north for a gasification
of flow-grade wood that's kind of on the
fence right now there's two sites
and to the point of mr man we have two
10-acre buildings
in berlin but it has nothing to do with
this power they're going to run on gas
they we actually passed the bill in our
committee back in 18
to the gas for an exclusion on the gas
for those plants for those two big
operations
if it
comes to fruition it's supposed to be
going forward right now
so um
it's it's it's kind of a hydroponic
plants they're two 10 acre buildings
they're huge
they're just down the road from this
plant but it's going to run on natural
gas because we have a gas line that runs
across coast county and they're going to
attack that
thank you representative murder
representative partial
thank you tom thank you chair um first
i'd love to hear you talk about the uh
how a broad solution for our forestry
industry i think until we solve that
we're going to continue to have problems
like this
i also agree with uh
representing some such
and that i've seen a two-year uh start
um audit would serve us much better than
a one year it's hard to make decisions
and we're not even talking about a full
year
it's hard to make decisions business
decisions in such a limited amount of
time
so that's one of my other concerns
um and my other concern i'm sure you
could address this one is
this bill seems like it had a lot of
input from a variety of sources the
department of energy is certainly
weighed in and said they're fully
prepared to take on the audit of this
company
fully okay that's that's that was my
main concern um i don't know if i'm
going to
go along with the amendment i'm
certainly going to
want to vote positively either for the
bill or the amendment and see this so
thank you representative thomas uh thank
you mr chair i'd like to hop on to what
uh representative murder said
my bill uh hb
one zero zero five
data has established a commission to
study the forest industry and
wood products to how we can better
support the forest industry uh
on with other things other than just
you know ratepayers
and i believe that
with that knowledge
this amendment extending
the bill a year
will give us time for the commission to
come together and give them time to come
up with alternative actions that will
that will help the forest industry uh
that's uh this commission is uh
greatly supported by the forest industry
of course and the forest service and the
and the governor and it's something that
we need to look at and so i see this
amendment as
time spent to allow the plan to operate
while this commission does its work and
while the doe does its work
for the books
so with that knowledge and this
commission being established which i
intend to be on
um
i support this amendment as a kind of a
stop debt measure until we
find out what the true solution could be
thank you representative callie pitts
this being a baseload plant which is
hasn't been mentioned yet is very
important i'd like a clarification
if possible that this bill will not
encourage or
will not cause any additional charge to
the ratepayers that the status quo with
this amendment is going to remain in
other words the money that's being
collected now will continue to be
collected
is that a correct assumption that this
is not going to
uh
raise the rates
in any way at this time
due to this amendment
the answer to that question is a little
bit up in the air
none of the three
orders apparently that are mentioned in
the amendment addresses cost recovery
i just learned that this morning
and
so there is the possibility
that cost recovery will be have will be
something we will have to
concern ourselves with in the inevitable
committee of conference
that
this bill
this amendment if if we pass it will
generate with the senate so
while i don't want to ignore that
idea i don't think we can fix it here
this morning but there is a way to fix
it before the bill gets to the
governor's desk
you're welcome representative oxenam
thank you mr chair
um in in your earlier remarks you spoke
about a study that would look at the
forest products industry more broadly as
being something that was in your
amendment
we've now heard about a bill that's
passed elsewhere which
apparently will provide such a study
what we have in this amendment is an
audit by the doe looking at the books of
this particular plant
um so
that's a it's a very big disconnect
between
when you
um gave us an overview of the amendment
you talked about this not being about
just one bill but being about the forest
products industry more broadly
uh so having having now heard about this
other bill it seems to me it would be
useful
for
your intention in bringing this
amendment to still be included here that
that this um
audit and report by the department of
energy
which is going to be very narrowly
focused
is not the intention of this body the
intention is to support a much broader
study
thank you
i think you might have misinterpreted my
earlier comments slightly
what i was talking about when i
introduced or did the overview for this
amendment
was the fact that the
additional year
that this bill provides or this
amendment provides
would allow
not only for a department of energy
investigation and audit
but would also allow for
discussions that i know are happening
because i've participated in them
about possible long-term solutions to
this
issue to this problem
i didn't say that this amendment
provided for such a study
and
i think you misinterpreted my comments
to to say that follow-up
i i did try to take down your remarks
because i understood them to be
important
and you said that you were looking for
a permanent solution in as the ultimate
goal
and that was not just for this one plant
but actually a solution for the forest
products industry
so i'm i'm just i'm just asking if
there's a way and maybe it's at the
committee of conference to incorporate
that notion that like the way you
handled the um sec with a we had a bill
that was a short-term solution temporary
and we had one that looked to the future
so that there would be a a a much better
and hopefully permanent solution forward
okay thank you for that suggestion
uh representative samsic
thank you mr chairman one last question
i i had conversations with some of the
stakeholders
and i was told that this plan is already
providing almost all the financial
information that is requested in this
amendment
is that correct and what's missing and
um
because it doesn't seem like
there's that much missing at this point
much of the language of this amendment
came from the department of energy
this is something that the department of
energy feels is necessary to gather
information sufficient
to make future long-term decisions about
how to proceed
in solving this problem
follow-up
are you aware of any other facility that
the department of energy is going to
look into their books and see how
they're being operated
i'm not aware of any now
further comments representative liewicki
thank you mr chairman it would seem that
getting the audit done would give us
some information which we may or may not
already have because the plant's going
to be paying so much a ton for wood
chips they're going to have so much
operating cost personnel and so forth
and that's going to give us a number
that should say this is what we can
afford to run on per kilowatt hour per
megawatt hour it just
it seems like fairly simple arithmetic
if we've got the
data to work with
thank you additional comments
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman i think that goes back to my
original concern
around what is it we're trying to get at
because we can get the math
right we can have that which we may not
have now which is a is a good thing
but the whole first paragraph here that
we've taken
the adjectives and and watered them down
a bit to make the plant not quite as
essential in terms of the language
the question still becomes regardless of
what that math ends up being how much
value is given to the other pieces of
what the plant provides to the new
hampshire economy are we taking into
consideration if we have no metrics and
we have no criteria for how that's being
weighed
then how do we know
how do we know what we're marching
towards in terms of having an audit
because an audit is simply
you know the pluses and the minuses but
not the value
i know it's a complicated question but
that's really what is before us
representative platt
there were
more than one plant in new hampshire and
each one of them could argue about value
i don't see any such argument leading to
ratepayer subsidies long-term period
i think also the answer to your question
would be we have a renewable portfolio
standard and that standard seeks to
answer the question how do we value
these these resources
any further discussion representative
sausage
well i couldn't resist uh thank you mr
chairman couldn't resist uh responding
to represent platt
it is true that these other plants are
not getting a subsidy in fact they
should be
having to be surcharged for the harm
they do to our environment and the
dependency we have to them from outside
fuel sources no they shouldn't be given
the subsidy
representative oxendine did you have
another comment
uh yes thank you very much um i i wanted
to call everyone's attention to the map
that was presented to us at the public
hearing that showed that the
the issue here is not simply this plant
but it's the sourcing of wood products
from across the state that the issue of
the value of this plant what it pays in
taxes to the city of berlin what it
provides in terms of jobs what it
provides in terms of people who sell
timbering equipment and
pick up trucks to people who actually
perform these jobs the value of this
goes way
way beyond
uh the issue of of the single plant and
and i'm i'm very very pleased that we
are going to have the commission that
came out of representative thomas's bill
that that's that's a great thing to have
out there but it's not solving this
problem and and one year doesn't even
successfully kick this down the road uh
it'll be
there was a timeline in one of the
attachments that came out yesterday that
said by the time the puc looks at this
and gets back
it the year will be practically used up
and it's not like the doe isn't doing a
lot of other things at the same time so
i i i feel like if we were to suspend
this session
and have an opportunity perhaps a small
group could work up an alternative
amendment that could take us uh forward
to some consensus but the the amendment
that we have before us is is not one
that uh that speaks to the the really
it
important dare i say vital
role that's played by this industry
which it it it has ramifications across
the economy and i i know uh questions
were raised at the public hearing which
talked about tourism
cross-country skiing hiking
did
this has
it did the ripples the ripples go
throughout the economy and i think we
need to be
giving this issue the the significant
attention it deserves and not rushing
ahead with a with an amendment that you
know purported to be a study but but
it's just an audit and
i i can't i can't see supporting it as
it is thank you
thank you you are absolutely right
all the things you talked about are why
this issue is so complicated
and why it's so hard to come up with a
permanent solution
and we're not going to come up with that
solution today
or even in this session year of this
legislature i don't believe
and that's why i believe we need another
year
to really
put our
noses to the grindstone
to come up with a
workable solution
and i think we've been going about it
the wrong way
subsidizing biomass plants is not the
best way to to support the forest
products industry
maybe what we should be focusing our
attention on is the forest products
industry and
just to throw out a couple of ideas and
i'm not saying that these are
a solution but to throw out a couple of
ideas
the state could buy low-grade timber and
then sell it back to the
biomass plants
at a steep discount
the state
could potentially do that it would
require taxpayer money but it could
happen
there are ways to solve this problem but
we need time to come up with a permanent
solution
and i think we have to go forward today
by amending this bill so that we'll have
time to do that
representative callie
just a pitts a quick question uh i i'm
going to support the amendment but who's
going to be working on this is is
partially st e going to be working on it
department of rev who's going to be
working on these solutions because they
really have to be worked on
and so i just would like
you perhaps to give some thought
where
this committee would fit in
since we are so concerned with these
issues and have been for many years
i think the overall guidance will come
from the commission that's established
by the bill that representative thomas
submitted
that commission
will give a lot of
guidance to the effort
to how we
solve the problem of how we support the
forest products industry
and
by so supporting that industry we can
probably find ways to help other
industries in the process
representative partial yes thank you
chair looking over the study committee
it looks like a fantastic committee i
noticed a sunset date on that as a
december of
2023 in order to have your work
completed which is a year after this
audit which may or may not make sense i
can understand that
um
my
question
is you foresee a situation does the uh
drafters of this amendment foresee a
situation where we'll be coming back
next year to authorize yet another stop
gap method of
bill in order to carry us over to 2023
when looking to get some final solutions
worked out
um i i really can't speculate on what
could happen a year from now i i see
i see this bill and this amendment
addressing the burgers power plant issue
directly in the forest industry
indirectly and i see that my bill uh on
the commission addresses the overall
state forest issue and products in a way
that we may either get away from
depending on
power plants for the for the forest
industry or to
use them in conjunction with the health
of the forest and other forest products
that that could be developed
so i really don't know what could happen
a year from now
i i will look at it
very critically
if they wanted to extend it past next
year
unless we come up with some permanent
solution
uh i will say
that i personally
should i be fortunate enough to get
reelected to this legislature
will undertake a major effort to come up
with a permanent solution to this
problem with legislation
next year
that is a personal commitment that i
will make
today
to all of you and to the public
that i will work diligently in
conjunction with the
forest products can commission and in
conjunction with any stakeholder
who has an interest in this subject
we will find a solution
it may not be a perfect solution and as
i said earlier it may not be easy to get
something passed
because they will there will be people
who will object to
anything you come up with right
and that's how you refine ideas and how
you improve ideas
that effort will happen because i'm
pledging you to to to you all today that
i will work to make it happen
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman um
in light of
your commitment here today and also in
light of the discussion we just had
about
various options um
i'm just
picking up the suggestion that
representative partial meant made before
how would you feel about this amendment
being amended to go from one year to two
years which would seem like a more
reasonable time to get stuff like this
done it's pretty complicated
my reaction to that is that two years is
too long
if we're going to get this done we need
a deadline
i was in business for 40 years and i
watched
projects that never got done because
they didn't have a deadline
you got to have a deadline to make
something happen
this amendment
establishes a really
aggressive deadline and that'll ensure
that we get something
done representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman
um
back to the deadline i'm project manager
here agree with you about the deadlines
um
i but is it the right deadline i think i
heard representative thomas say that he
would not be interested in an extension
if we get to the end of one year which
would be may of next year
and we don't have a final solution to to
quote you a final solution
if there are dependencies in terms of
what's going through with hb01005
then perhaps it would make sense to go
18 months to november so that we
actually are in a position where we have
the outcomes
of the decisions that are being made
from that study committee which is
intertwined with the potential solution
representative mcgee raised a good point
of clarification that
i neglected to
elucidate earlier
this extension does last until november
of 2023 it doesn't end in may
because the current order
that it extends ends in november of 2022
so by
extending it by a year it takes it out
to november of 2023. okay i'm sorry i
didn't clarify that earlier
representative thomas
thank you miss cheer i'm i'm sorry i i
i try to choose my my words carefully
and just for the record
i said that i would look at any
extension
very critically
i did not say that i would not be
interested i just i would look at it
very critically so i just you know just
would like to have it clarified
representative bernardi
thank you mr chairman
although the broader issue is the forest
products industry generally i think the
the immediate issue with this bill is
the
economic viability of this plant
can it be uh continue to be operated
just using the rps subsidies it gets or
is it viable on its own like the
like the smaller biomass plant that
operates up there
is
or does it and can it be
ever in a place where it will repay that
58 million dollar uh
debt
and we need to understand those
economics i think this bill
puts us in a position to get that
information through the audit so we can
make a decision
should we go forward and continue to
support this kind of operation
or does it need some other additional
assistance and are we willing to grant
that or not
that's that's what's on the table i
support this amendment
thank you representative lewicki thank
you mr chairman
one observation is that this plant does
try to operate pretty much continuously
except for two weeks shut down
and the other plants have the option of
running when they choose and so they can
choose their time and timing and they
can run when the price of electricity is
higher and so it's apples and oranges
and economically
this plant can do the same
representative oxenum
uh
one point uh i thank you very much for
clearing up the november 23 deadline
that that was very helpful
um i i asked that perhaps you reconsider
your commitment to put in a bill in
september of 22
and hold off uh and
allow that to be a commitment for the
lsr window which would be november of 23
and would align
uh much much more closely with the um
oh it said we don't get a november
window when we in a non-election year do
we so at least september of 23 for that
window
okay further comments
seeing none i think it's time to call
for a vote so i asked the clerk to call
for a vote on the question of the
adoption of the amendment 2022-1788-h
to senate bill 271 mr clerk
thank you mr chair
uh representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative knighter yes
representative mirner yes representative
platfordsvs representative berezini yes
represent bernardi yes representative
campbell's
yes
representative please yes
representative white yes
representative samsich no representative
cali pitts yes
represent man yes
representative oxenam
representative lewicki
yes
and i apologize for calling you so late
representative blue wiggy but that's the
way this is laid out so
uh
representative kelly
no
representative mcgee
yes
representative mcwilliams no
representative creation
no
representative leflem
representative lucius
not partial not partial sorry i like
both things sorry
i'm partial to your last name
yes okay
and the chair yes the vote is 16 to 6.
by a vote of 16 to 6
the committee amendment
10 or 1788 h is adopted i now move the
adoption of
senate bill 271 as amended and
recognized representative thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt senate bill 271 as amended by
amendment
2022-1788
do we need any further discussion
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the role on the question
of
the
passage of senate bill 271 as amended mr
clerk just one second and i shall do so
okay catching up
uh i have to label all of these while
the clerk is doing his administrative
duties i would remind everyone that if
you so desire
you can join
members of the committee who will be
touring the control room
of the
eversource
utility this afternoon starting at 12 30
at their facility in manchester
i understand they're going to provide us
with some lunch before the tour
and uh i would urge you all to attend if
you plan to attend and you haven't
notified us already let ms gomash know
before she leaves here today that you
will be in attendance okay starting with
the roll call mr chair go ahead
representative thomas yes representative
harrington yes representative nader yes
representative mirner yes representative
platfords yes representative berezni yes
represent bernardi yes representative
campbell's yes representative pleasure
yes representative white yes
representative samsich
no
representative cali pitts
representative mann
yes
represent oxidant
no reps of luiki
yes
representative kelly
representative mcgee
yes
represent mc williams yes
representative creation
representative laflin
yes
uh representative partial
and the chair yes
the vote is uh 20 to 2.
by a vote of 22 senate bill 271
is adopted as amended by 2022 1788h
there be a minority report
representative samsic will write the
minority report
and i thank you all that was uh
a spirited
an informative debate i think we aired
the issue thoroughly and i appreciate
your hard work
represents what would your uh
alternative motion be for you writing
the minority report for
yes
okay
all right
let's uh let's call this quits for today
that's the end of the exact session for
senate bill 271 once again i thank you i
look forward to seeing many of you uh
at the
eversource control room tour if you
don't do not join us there
then we will be
gathering on may 24th for lunch and some
full committee work sessions
until then i thank you all
and good morning